welcome to the splits video Garlett
galit whatever from current from spain
and we have a dutch defense i played
Bishop b5 why do we get set up that he's
playing here what does see what would
assist what does it do now g6 and now if
I go age for this is looks a bit
unnatural this 97 if he goes age six now
I can take f5 and now I can't play age
five isn't this and comes the woeful
black
yeah okay but doesn't it doesn't look
like i don't really trust that for black
but how to how to play he might might be
able to play a five this is Sir the
thing I need to keep in mind but ok
first I probably need to do their
channel if I am maybe it's erm it's best
to to play c4 after all crash arising t5
so that II five is more difficult to
play and I'm sorry curve it away I've
got a slight cold okay so let's develop
it looks like a pretty normal position
besides the cleared H file yeah and then
how to place this Knight f3 or eat ooh
f4 I still like a three more I can maybe
play 92 to f4 anyway later he's got some
problems with with the his development
if this night is moving on on this 7 f
95 how interesting yeah I'm going to
cancel long anyway maybe maybe night
year eve form maybe ninety four years is
going to do
yeah well I need to do this problem ok
this was clear they have to pawn this is
this is hanging
mmm still I wonder is this if I'd if I
take d5 wonder if I have some some
tactical technical way to play like cd5
and then sacrificing when you form okay
I haven't I haven't calculated this
completely but ok didn't take him sisas
understand so if i take here and take a
form for Queenie six this is looking
looking very dangerous
hmm i'm not sure if it is really working
it is dangerous that's clear but is it
winning Queen e6 check King here and
then I can move the night okay but I
need to do it probably anyway now I'm
down to one minute 14 yeah okay okay
this is the first game of a session and
those are always tricky usually I do
warm up game but once in a while I just
I just start and say okay what the heck
let's just play so clean geez the 96 is
the idea if he moves the night half
Queen g6 check it's it's it's clearly
dangerous for black but is it winning
okay so i can take here now what is
slightly problem i don't see it this is
jack is checkmate checkmate yeah this is
lucky for me but I spent so much time
here so I are pretty much needed to mate
but then it was probably probably bad
food like this position let's say let's
check this
what the computer wants to play Knight
e5 here and giving it says it's
instantly winning I don't understand why
I thought this was was the problem but
this is actually a maid that didn't see
that has to mate like here check ok I
always check always get to this at the
end and then this Bishop f6 ok so 95 was
better but ok it didn't have any time I
needed to move so maybe this is good as
well no it's um not as good at least 95
was an instant win and he can defend
with Knight f6 yeah I suspected that
this is the best move but ok like this
it still assume it's dangerous for black
but computers asses hawlucha Howard yeah
i I don't I don't even have a check here
but what I can what I do have I can I
can open up the F file right it's
clearly a dangerous position for black
but not not an instant winner like the
other line Queen h5 is the computer move
and now something like this yeah this is
maybe this is the society's is very
dangerous hope like how to her too hard
to tell without proper analysis I mean
from a theoretical point of view are
from from an analytical point of view um
this is good for white because of this
95 so check this the whole concept was
was ok what I wonder is still i played
this on the sum
that cannot take him which is probably
truly I can take the end have a similar
position yeah this is winning okay and
on this I thought I can take and this is
also working yeah okay so this was
pretty well pretty well you're not
calculated I was just thinking okay this
should work yeah the whole the whole
black position is shaky and if he
doesn't play 94 which she cannot play
obviously it's um it's hard to make a
move let's say something like this I can
take and this this always opens up 495
this is just where the night wants to go
yeah it's a it's very tricky one neat
little trick at the beginning of the
game was here after h4 she plays age 6
there's this this funny movie winning
win against the left because of the
checkmate the media this is my 97 was
was a bit strange to my he can play em
yeah c6 saw the moves that still protect
upon him all right nice game thanks for
watching